el primero de octubre de 2017 fue un día
lluvioso en Barcelona
cientos de miles de personas salieron a
defender los puntos de votación y pese a
la prohibición del Estado español más de
dos millones de personas participaron en
el referendo de independencia de
Cataluña
pero más allá de los votos el mundo se
hizo eco de la respuesta desde Madrid en
una dura represión con imágenes de
policías españoles golpeando a
ciudadanos que trataban de votar empezó
entonces un mes de octubre frenético con
manifestaciones proindependencia pero
también la respuesta españolista
en ese clima el ex presidente de
Cataluña Carles puigdemont declaró
durante 8 segundos la independencia aquí
de salir con la mitad del gobierno a
Bélgica mientras que la otra mitad
ingresó en prisión uno de ellos fue el
ex vicepresidente Catalán Uriel
yunqueras estábamos seguros que se iba a
celebrar el refrendo a pesar de que la
represión En aquel momento ya era
extraordinaria con el gobierno del
socialista Pedro Sánchez la tensión bajo
indultando a los presos que habían
recibido condenas de hasta 13 años el
Movimiento Político pese a gobernar en
la región de Cataluña se encuentra
fracturado cinco años después pero el
pasado 11 de septiembre el Día Nacional
de Cataluña las calles volvieron a
llenarse de cientos de miles de personas
por independencia
se ve difícil Ahora tiene unos niveles
de apoyo muy importantes por encima del
40% en estos momentos en la opinión
pública catalana y por lo tanto no diría
que es imposible Cataluña está ubicada
en el noreste de España y es fronteriza
con Francia actualmente el gobierno
español y el Catalán mantienen una mesa
de negociación en el año previo a unas
nuevas elecciones generales en España